Cómo llega Gustavo Petro estos seis
meses de mandato Gracias por la
introducción Santi Gustavo Petro llega
ahora mismo con un 44% de favorabilidad
y es un momento clave en su gobierno ya
que como comentabas quiere buscar llevar
adelantes distintas reformas sociales
destacan laboral con la que busca pues
mayores pagos nocturnos de horas extras
también mayores vacaciones incluso
aumentar bueno reducir en este caso de
48 a 40 horas la jornada semanal también
destaca la pensional en la que busca
centralizar las pensiones de Colombia en
la empresa pública en colpensiones y
estas dos reformas no generan tanta
controversia especialmente entre sus
votantes Ya que en Colombia El 50% de la
población trabaja en la informalidad y
muchas personas también declaran de que
no van a poder pensionarse nunca sí que
genera más controversias la tercera
reforma social que se quieren acometer
en estos meses que es la de la salud y
es que la ministra de salud Carolina
corcho ha dicho en distintas ocasiones
que quiere acabar con las empresas
prestadoras de salud de servicios y
Buscar un sistema más público esto en un
país como Colombia donde realmente la
población no tiene tantas críticas o no
está tan enfrentada con su sistema de
salud junto a las sociales también hay
una reforma interesante de comentar de
la justicia que es la ley del
sometimiento Y es que estaba al lado de
la ley de la paz total y es una ley que
tienen que acometer en la justicia
después de conversaciones que han tenido
la fiscalía y Gustavo Petro para poder
negociar tener también beneficios
penitenciarios o de la justicia a grupos
armados pero que no sean políticos sino
criminales y dedicados al narcotráfico
hablemos ahora de los que han sido
considerados como éxitos o fracasos de
su gestión sí Santi es que aunque ahora
vemos también como mucha prisa en llevar
estas reformas recordamos que son seis
meses y ya todo lo que hemos hablado
también en sus primeros 100 días hubo
como una carrera reloj y es cuando se
consiguió la reforma tributaria que
aumentó el presupuesto en 4.000 millones
de dólares y era de carácter progresivo
también el congreso dio luz verde a esa
ley de la paz Total que va de la mano de
la sometimiento que comentábamos y en la
que vemos como Gustavo Petro tiene entre
sus retos entre sus deseos como
presidente pasar a la historia por el
cese de las armas del Ln el ejército de
liberación nacional que es la guerrilla
activa más antigua de América Latina De
hecho también ahí vienen un poco los
esos aspectos negativos que se han
comentado y es que el 31 de diciembre
Gustavo Petro en Twitter dijo que había
llegado al César fuego con distintos
grupos entre los que incluía el eln pero
días más tardes el eln le desmintió Y
esto es una característica que se viene
señalando del gobierno y es un pelín de
improvisación que también han llevado a
enfrentamientos entre ministros tanto en
la reforma de la salud pero también en
esa transición energética que ha
prometió el gobierno de Gustavo Petro
que enfrenta algunos de sus ministros
definitivamente Luis son varios frentes
los que tiene abiertos y recordemos
tengamos en cuenta que estamos hablando
de seis meses de gestión no falta
todavía un largo trayecto por delante
hablemos ahora de lo que pasa en las
calles hay convocatorias para
movilizaciones la próxima semana
contanos Quiénes la están convocando
como dice Santi en la próxima semana el
14 de febrero el propio Gustavo Petro el
presidente ha convocado sus partidarios
a que salgan a las calles Pues a
defender esas reformas sociales y esa
Paz Total que busca Gustavo Petro y un
día después será la oposición la que
haya convocado unas marchas precisamente
contra estas reformas sin embargo
Gustavo petroa ha conseguido un gobierno
en el que hay sectores progresistas y
liberales y también acuerdos externos de
partidos que llegan hasta la derecha
como el partido conservador esto ha
desarticulado un poco a la oposición
donde no se ve un gran líder no incluso
grandes figuras como Álvaro Uribe el
expresidente se ha reunido ya tres veces
con Gustavo Petro y lleva una oposición
masiva lo mismo pasa con una figura como
María Fernanda cabal y es que su marido
Félix lafour y el jefe de la patronal de
los ganaderos también está formando
parte de las negociaciones de paz con el
eln con el gobierno de Gustavo PE